Welcome to AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
I am your maitre d' Seita.
This program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
By the way, the most famous movie phrase of all time is...
..."I'll be back."
You know the movie, right?
This is Terminator, Arnold Schwarzenegger, the California governor.
Okay, the second most popular movie phrase of all time is this,...
..."Frankly my dear, I don't give a damn."
Do you know what this movie is?
Yes, a lot of people know it and so should you.
This movie is Rhett Butler in Gone With The Wind.
A little bit of trivia, I thought you should know.
Okay, today's class...
Get out of here!
Wow! Get out of here!
So, practice a set phrase.
Wouldn't that be something!
Wouldn't that be something.
I think that's Brad Pitt.
Wow! Wouldn't that be something?
Wouldn't that be something.
Okay, let's practice.
Please repeat after me.
Get out of here!
Second one, wouldn't that be something.
Wouldn't that be something!
Wouldn't that be something.
Alright, please practice.
Okay, that's it for today.
And next week, there'll be more contents to help you become the native maestro.
See you later.